.
TRACE GALLAGHER, THANKS SO MUCH
FOR THAT.
IF YOU HAVE CONCERNS THAT THE
U.S. INTEL AGENCIES THAT ARE
VAST AND VERY POWERFUL CAN
LISTEN TO ANYTHING THEY WANT TO
INCLUDE IN PRIVATE
COMMUNICATIONS ARE OUT OF
CONTROL AND OPERATING IN EFFECT
AS THEIR OWN COUNTRIES, YOU WILL
BE REASSURED BY PEOPLE WITHIN
WASHINGTON WASHINGTON THAT
ACTUALLY THE CONSTITUTION GIVES
THEM OVERSIGHT IN THE FORM OF
THE CONGRESS, THE CONGRESS
OVERSEES THE INTEL AGENCIES AND
THEY DO IT THROUGH A COMMITTEE
IN THE HOUSE AND A COMMITTEE IN
THE SENATE, THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITIES.
TAKE A CLOSE LOOK AT WHO SITS ON
THOSE COMMITTEES.
IN THE HOUSE, THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE HAS A MAN
CALLED ERIC SWALWELL, A MEMBER
OF CONGRESS WHO WE KNOW HAS HAD
SEX WITH A CHINESE SPY, AND YET
HE REMAINS ON THE INTEL
COMMUNITY.
DOES THAT SHAKE YOUR FAITH A
LITTLE BIT?
IT TURNS OUT ACCORDING TO NEW
REPORTING FROM BREITBART NEWS
THAT THERE IS A CLASSIFIED
REPORT THAT DESCRIBES IN SOME
DETAIL, APPARENTLY,
ERIC SWALWELL'S RELATIONSHIP
WITH THAT CHINESE SPY BUT IT
REMAINS CLASSIFIED, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WILL REVEAL IT.
ALEX MARLOW IS THE EDITOR IN
CHIEF OF BREITBART NEWS, HE
JOINS US TONIGHT WITH THIS
STORY.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING ON AND
CONGRATULATIONS ON BREAKING THIS
STORY.
ERIC SWALWELL HAD SEX WITH A
CHINESE SPY, THAT IS NOT
SPECULATION, THAT IS KNOWN.
APPARENTLY THE U.S. INTEL
AGENCIES KNOW IT.
THEY HAVE A CLASSIFIED REPORT ON
HIM, WHERE DOES THIS LEAVE US?
>> LAST NIGHT, MATT BOYLE OUR
POLITICAL EDITOR FOR
BREITBART NEWS BROKE WHAT ARE
PRETTY EXPLOSIVE DETAILS ABOUT
NOT JUST HIS SEX LIFE BUT THE
WAY OUR HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE IS COMPROMISED.
WE KNEW SHE WAS INFILTRATING
OPERATIONS WITHIN THE
UNITED STATES, VARIOUS OFFICES
AND HAVING RELATIONSHIPS WITH
UP-AND-COMING POLITICIANS BEFORE
SHE ABRUPTLY LEFT THE COUNTRY A
FEW YEARS AGO AND WE KNEW SHE
HAD AN INTIMATE RELATIONSHIP
WITH HIM, NOW APPARENTLY WE DO.
AS OF NOW, SWALLWELL HASN'T
DENIED THIS IS DEEP PENETRATION
BY THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT.
>> WE DIRECTLY ASKED HIM TO COME
ON AND COMMENT ON THIS, IT SETS
UP A VERY UNCOMFORTABLE AND BAD
DYNAMIC, IF I'M YOUR BOSS BUT
YOU HAVE INFORMATION ON MY WEIRD
PROCLIVITIES, I'M NOT REALLY
YOUR BOSS ANYMORE, YOU HAVE
POWER OVER ME AND THAT'S WHAT IT
LOOKS LIKE HERE -- THE INTEL
WORLD KNOWS THE DETAILS OF HIS
SEXUAL RELATIONSHIP WITH A
CHINESE SPY THAT HE SUPPOSED TO
BE OVERSEEING THEM?
THAT IS NOT THE WAY IT'S
SUPPOSED TO WORK, IS THAT?
>> IS IN THE RUSSIAN WORD FOR
THAT KOMPROMAT?
THE ONLY REASON TO KNOW IS TO
KEEP THIS REPORT SECRET AND
CLASSIFIED AS PROTECT HIS
FEELINGS.
THE CHAIR OF THE COMMUNITY HAS
COVERED FOR SWALWELL THE ENTIRE
TIME, THIS IS A DEEPLY
COMPROMISED INDIVIDUAL AND WE
DON'T KNOW THE EXTENT TO WHICH
HE'S BEEN COMPROMISED OR IF
THERE ARE OTHER SPIES OUT THERE?
>> Tucker: ARE THERE OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE INTEL COMMUNITIES
WHO HAVE HAD SEX WITH CHINESE
SPIES?
>> THEY WON'T COME CLEAN WITH US
WHO IS ON THESE COMMITTEES AND
HOW MUCH DETAIL IS NOT JUST OUR
OWN INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES AND WE
STUMBLED UPON THIS STORY BUT HOW
MUCH INFORMATION TO PEOPLE LIKE
KNOWN COMMUNISTS SPIES HAVE
ABOUT OUR CONGRESSPEOPLE?
>> Tucker: THE FIGHT
ADMINISTRATION SHOULD DECLASSIFY
THIS IMMEDIATELY TO RESTORE
FAITH IN T